はいみなさんこんにちは同源ですと今日は言語学校についてちょっと話してみたいと
思います
僕は hvd んまえか練りしてるの
りんご学校について話していま a 壁ですデハオリーブ油いい
日本語の言語学科について話してコメです how are you doing でし
た
脱実改正英語じゃぁ後言語学校のいいところは実際にもそのネイティブの先生からの
アドバイスを受けることができるって言うと喧嘩今言語学
いけなくなってそうだけど普段はっていう話はいいましています普段だったら言語学校
必携ぱ実際のネイル this
あと宿題宿題が嫌いだっていう人が多いんですけれども宿題やらなきゃいけないって
いうプレッシャーが握手そうでやらなかったけどそれでも日本のテレビ結構出てるよ
やっと村酒のボードは山
どこいくドバト試験試験っていうのは実を
もすごくいいものでやって感じの pop quiz やりましょう
敬礼を書いてくださいストップそっちは僕の好きな言語学校を紹介します
東京の学校なんでしょうかどう下東京いたことありますか
はいありますというか普通に大学時代は東京に住ん
じゃあ荒山取ってキープしましょう品川からスタート
品川品川行五反田を先でしょ
はい出来ましただから言語学校のいいところはネイティブと話せることでしょ
そうだだったらどうげんたべ茶飲んで外国人だから
いやそこはもう切れをかけてしそこはいいだろううーん
ni
っていうか痙攣かけるのってホント凄いなお前
でしょ